[Music]
coastal cities across the globe are
planning how they will keep the sea away
as it rises
one solution
just move the city how much would it
cost
how do you lift a building
and where is this already happening
[Music]
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you moved an entire city
populations of people are already
fleeing climate change across the globe
in north america the alaskan village of
newtowk was faced with a mega slump
caused by melting permafrost
as the layers of frozen soil melted
the ground became unstable
homes started to sink and crumble
it took over 20 years of preparation for
the 380 inhabitants of new talk to move
and they only transplanted the people
not the buildings
but what would happen if a larger city
had to move
new york city is home to more than eight
million people and more than one million
buildings
it also faces an increasing risk of
coastal flooding
relocating that many people would be
daunting enough but
throw in the challenges of moving all
the buildings and now you've got quite
the puzzle for a team of engineers
to prepare you'd have to figure out
where you're going to place the new new
york city
you'd have to clear the land of any
obstacles and maybe level it out if the
area is especially hilly
you might even need to build new roads
to get there
and before you even begin moving
buildings you'd want to pour the
foundations and install utilities
aging pipes are an issue in older cities
so at least you'd have the opportunity
to use new materials for sewage water
and gas
now you'd start transplanting structures
because of how complicated and lengthy
this is
you divide the city up into small
sections and take a phased approach
after making sure that all citizens of a
specific section have moved to a
temporary spot
you would disconnect all utilities and
remove any wires above ground
then you excavate the building by
digging around it and cutting into the
foundation walls
you'd insert steel beams into the
foundation openings to bear the weight
of the building
then after placing hydraulic jacks
underneath the steel beams
you'd lift the house
because the hydraulic jack system keeps
the house completely level
you can actually leave the furniture
inside
with the building lifted above its
foundation you'd slide beams underneath
it which will help you pull the building
onto special dollies with rubber tires
these dollies would be attached to a
truck and the truck would transport the
structure to its new location
[Music]
and because the foundation is already
poured the building simply has to be
lowered onto it connect the utilities
and you're done
it's kind of like magic except with a
lot of people power
time and money
how much time and money
[Music]
well the largest building ever moved was
the fugang building which weighs fifteen
thousand hundred 140 tons
it was only moved 36 meters but it took
11 days
the farther the structure has to travel
and the taller the building
the longer it will take
you definitely need multiple crews of
people working at the same time to move
the city as quickly as possible
[Applause]
karuna sweden is currently transplanting
its city of almost 23 000 people
they have been moving the town piece by
piece since 2004.
their new location is four kilometers to
the east
the move has already cost over
532 million dollars and the cost will
likely double before the move is
finished
based on those numbers moving the city
of new york would cost more than 370
trillion dollars
that's a lot of money but it could be
cheaper than rebuilding the entire city
moving a house costs between 50 to 75
percent of what a comparable new
building would cost
it would also be more environmentally
friendly since you'd reuse old material
and in some cases buildings have
histories that are priceless to some
people
[Music]
one option to help pay for the move
would be to get a corporation to help
sponsor the new city
but would you want to live in a new york
city run by a mega corporation
well
that's a story
for another
what if
you